For more than 40 years, CNN has offered
a front row seat to history in the making.
Why am I under arrest?
It's a hoax set up.
Join us
as we turn back the clock to expose
Osama bin Laden and watch two stories
that have defined our times.
There are no words to say.
O.J. Simpson.
This is CNN's Rewind.
It was June 1994.
President Bill Clinton
was serving his second year in office.
The story of Nancy Kerrigan
and Tonya Harding had overshadowed
the recent Olympics.
Kurt Cobain, Richard Nixon and Jackie O.
Had recently died.
But on June 17th, as sports fans settled
in for game five of the NBA Finals.
Something unexpected was about to unfold
live on television.
Monday, June 13.
10 minutes past midnight Pacific Time.
The bodies of Nicole Simpson and Ronald
Wild Goldman are found outside Ms..
Simpson's
Brentwood condominium Wednesday, June 15.
Police sources
confirm a match of the bloodstains
found at the crime scene
and O.J. Simpson's home.
Later, police will not confirm reports
Simpson
is a suspect.
Thursday,
June 16, Simpson attends the funeral
of his slain ex-wife
with the couple's two children.
The L.A.
District Attorney's office
awaits lab reports needed to seek
a warrant for Simpson's arrest.
Friday, June 17.
Simpson is charged with two counts
of murder with special circumstances.
Tonight
on Larry King Live, an American tragedy.
O.J. Simpson vanishes
after being charged for a crime
his fans never dreamed he could commit.
Now live from Washington, here's
Larry King.
Unbelievably, the most watched, most
wondered about man in America
has gone missing tonight.
He apparently disappeared from
under the noses of his lawyers and doctors
this afternoon,
dodged an arranged surrender
and vanished into the Los Angeles haze.
O.J. Simpson, one of our most public
figures, even before this
week's incredible events, is now
one of our most wanted ever,
a football star, movie star, TV sports
analyst, commercial pitchman
is described as armed and dangerous,
possibly suicidal.
And if found, he could face the death
penalty for the murders of Nicole
Simpson and Ronald Goldman.
In a note he wrote before he fled,
Simpson denied any responsibility
for his ex-wife's murder, insisting
they had a great relationship.
There is nothing like this in memory.
Nothing
is. Our
guest is John Mack, president of the L.A.
Urban League.
Let's go to some phone calls.
Pensacola, Florida, hello.
Perhaps
he doesn't think that maybe the money
that athletes are being paid today.
Okay.
I'm going to have to interrupt this call.
I understand we're going to go
to a live picture in Los Angeles.
Is that correct?
Okay.
This is Interstate five and this is
courtesy of KLR, one of our L.A.
affiliates.
Police believe that right now that O.J.
Simpson is in that car.
Okay.
Police believe he is in that vehicle,
slowed down on the ground.
Let's pick up what the local broadcaster
is saying at this point,
that the the officers would do just about
whatever they do on any type of person,
telling them that they hope they believe
that this vehicle is registered to.
Our colleague was one of
his oldest friends, a
teammate at Southern Cal,
the pressure the vehicle and just hope.
And they believe that I'm telling who's
the other person
they're looking for who was with O.J.
earlier today.
They believe again,
they believe that this is the car.
We do not know.
This is the car
trying to just stay on top of all of the
vehicles down there
just in case the vehicle did get away.
The law enforcement vehicle
would be able to maintain visual
at all times. But
apparently the assumption is that Cowlings
driving and Simpson is a passenger
and police are trailing
or the police are making
no attempt to pull this car over. Hey.
Hey, Pat, That person
yelling, Hey, Pat,
is it Cal in Los Angeles?
And that's their helicopter.
John, do you hear me? Yes.
Back our guest, the president of the L.A.
Urban League. Yes.
What do you make of this?
I'll tell you, this is high drama, Larry.
I didn't expect to be a part of this, but
I you know, it's
I, I really it's it's it'll be interesting
to see who's really in that car.
All right. We're going to stay with this.
Obviously,
the cars not exceeding the speed limit.
The California Highway Patrol,
there's another helicopter.
Could be a police
helicopter is trailing it.
They're going south through Orange County.
But nobody is pulling this car over.
And we could only guess as to why not.
I guess they're just being they may fear
that there are arms in that car.
They may fear that Simpson may harm
himself.
Right.
They may fear that they're not in the car
and it's just a registered car
and someone else is driving. Right.
Yeah, I think they are being
they are correct
in proceeding with a great deal of caution
here.
Now, they are northbound on I-5.
That's a correction.
We had said southbound on I-5.
Now that northbound in I-5,
that would make them heading toward L.A.,
coming back toward Los Angeles. Yes.
Now, police
radio
saying that Simpson has a gun at his head.
Police radio saying that Simpson,
the passenger in the car,
has a gun at his head,
which is explain
why they haven't been stopping
and why they haven't moved up alongside.
Oh, no.
He the voice saying, oh, no.
Is John Mack, president of the L.A.
Urban League of. You're just joining us.
This is Larry King live in Washington,
reviewing a car apparently being driven
by Al calling one of OJ's
oldest friends and a former teammate
at Southern Cal.
911. What are you reporting?
This is everything you see.
I have O.J. in the car. Okay.
Why are you afraid?
I'm coming up the five Freeway.
Okay. Right now, we all we are. Okay.
But you got to celebrate this
because he's still alive,
that he got a gun to his head.
Okay, hold on a minute, Monica.
Let me take us
to the house and hold on a moment.
What's. What's your name?
My name is also.
You know, I am goddammit, something.
All right, sir.
Hold on just a moment.
You know, I don't want to.
All right.
What's your name?
Oh, hello.
The Highway
Patrol does not want to intimidate.
And I repeat,
do not want to intimidate this vehicle
into doing anything
that they really don't want him to do.
And the main thing is to get him pulled
over as safely as possible.
And there's only a couple of ways
that'll happen.
One is him just pulling over
and or running out of gas.
So at this point,
we can only pray that they'll be able
to pull this off in a safe measure.
It is now 7:00 in Los Angeles.
This would be near bumper
to bumper normally, apparently with people
listening to radios,
they're all getting off that highway
all clear over to the right.
You can see cars slowing down above it.
There are no lights on these freeways.
So they're all paying attention
to their radios.
And that's he's just cross under 91.
We had no idea what that was.
The city of Los Angeles has been rocked
these past couple of years.
And this is just part
of this continuing saga. You.
Reuters
is reporting that the police tracked O.J.
Simpson through his cellular phone.
Apparently, he was on the cellular phone
and they tracked him through there
and that's how they picked up this car.
Now, all traffic is being cleared off this
freeway, either through their own venue
or through instructions
coming from somewhere.
These people obviously, there's no one
paying any attention to anything else
but this story.
So they're working at all
the cars on the bridge.
Man, that's a helicopter reporting,
talking to Cal, saying, look at all
those cars on that bridge looking down.
This is a living drama and there's there's
nothing else you can say, but
we're going to stay with it
conceivably as a cellular phone.
He could be on that phone right now
talking to his attorney,
talking to somebody.
There's no rule book on this
because this hasn't happened.
The California
Highway Patrol has now confirmed to CNN
that it is definitely a vehicle
and they are almost certain that O.J.
is in the passenger seat
that we're just now crossing.
The 605 California toll is also telling.
So we're starting up
hitting as deep as I was in my area
from north east long Beach.
But again, O.J.
appears to be holding a gun to his head.
Well, David, the the 405 is not too much
in this area.
He wants to go to his mother's house
in Long Beach or that he wants to go able
His mother is at
the cars
on top of the screen,
heading east on that freeway,
I guess, slowing down to look
and get a glimpse of
one of the icons of American sports
history, O.J.
Simpson
on this tragic June day
in a city besieged with stories.
When you think what can top one
with another, another occurs.
Ordinary Jim Hill, OJ's friend
and sportscaster, has been on the radio.
The last thing Jim said was O.J.
You were a man.
You are a man. Here's one of those.
Be a man.
Just pull right on over.
Stop right now.
This thing is only going to get worse.
You've been hearing
and we've been hearing here
where people are are coming out
and they're just so distraught
and they love you and they
they've admired you for the longest time.
Please, gentlemen, pull.
Earlier today,
Robert SHAPIRO had arranged for O.J.
to turn himself
in. Doctors were in attendance.
They were all going to go together
in a car
because they were worried about suicide.
When they went downstairs
from a conference room and OJ's house,
he was gone.
Then at about 1030,
SHAPIRO did not hear again from him.
We were then had a press conference later
in which Piro announced that O.J.
had written a sealed letters
to his mother, to his children,
had codified the will
that means might have changed and added to
and had the will certified circumstantial
and then wrote a letter to the public
against O.J.
in which O.J.
said such things as I have
nothing to do with Nicole's murder.
I loved her.
Recently, we've come to an understanding
for now, we're not right for each other.
It was tough splitting up to a rest,
but then it goes on in a rambling account,
saying goodbye to people
and saying he was pretty much at the end.
It certainly reads like a suicide note.
On the phone now we have psychiatrist Dr.
Tom Linden and Dr. Tom, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Chris, at this point,
what would you deduce psychiatrically?
Well, I can't obviously get inside O.J.
Simpson's mind right now,
but judging from other experiences
with suicidal people, number one,
he has to be taken very, very seriously.
Number two,
quite often people who are suicidal
at that
time are also potentially homicidal.
And that's something that the police
are very well aware of
in such a chaotic
and sometimes crazy world.
Everybody needs heroes.
And there are I'm sure
millions of Americans had look to O.J.
as a hero.
And when a hero is in trouble,
it's very, very hard to accept.
And I think that's that's
probably the feeling of a lot of people.
Certainly my feeling.
His former fame coach, John McKay,
one of the legendary coaches,
has gotten on public radio to tell O.J.
that he loves them.
Beg him to please give himself up.
Again, you see traffic in the south lanes
stopping and looking,
police cars trailing, other traffic
stopping
off to the right, getting toward
8:00 in Los Angeles,
about 25 minutes away from 8:00.
If they stayed right where they're going
now, they're going to go right toward
the Beverly Hills or Santa monica,
Brentwood, areas where O.J.
lives
and where the two people killed
also lived.
There's the Ford Bronco O.J.
reported in the back.
There apparently appears to be something
in the front as well as something
sticking out of the right hand
side of that car.
And again, they're losing the picture
a little is KTLA.
Other reports we're getting is that O.J.
appears in to be a little incoherent
and they've picked him up
a little on the phone
and the voice sounds slurred.
There you see LAX. In fact,
you see a plane landing at L.A.X.
And I don't know what that is.
Yeah, just let me get to my house.
Okay. We're going to do this, sweaty.
I'll give you what you give me.
I'll give you my whole body.
Okay. Need to get them help.
Okay, We're going to do that.
Just throw the gun out the window
like we're not going to body.
I'm going to let you go up there.
Just throw it out the window, please.
You're scaring everybody.
Toss it, please.
Too many people love you, man.
Don't give it all up. Don't hurt
everybody.
You're going to hurt everybody.
I'm just going to leave
no one to deal with Nicole.
That's all I'm going to do.
So, listen,
if you think about everybody else
on the freeway,
I couldn't do it in a field.
I want to do it at her grave.
I want to do it at my house.
You're not going to do anything.
Too many people love you.
Your kids, your mother,
your friends, A.C., everybody.
You've got the whole
world. Don't throw it away.
Don't throw it away Now.
Come on, O.J., we understand that Dr.
Michael Baden can hear us.
How are you, Michael?
Hi, Larry.
Sorry to be talking to you
at this time ago.
You were
you were called out to as an expert
on the cause of death and type of death
and how the deaths would have occurred,
as he says in his own letter
and as he said to you,
he never admitted killing right?
Well, and certainly not to me.
You seem to be bewildered, Larry, as to
why people felt he had killed his family
when he was bereaved
and very upset at what had happened
in the sand,
why the suspicion was pointing to him.
All right, Michael,
based on your understanding
of all these things
and in talking
with the other psychologists
and psychiatrists, could we, in fact,
have O.J.
being totally in a non-real world here
and not accepting the fact
that he may have done what he did?
Sure. Sure.
He was so depressed
and he so upset that we were concerned
that he was could hurt himself.
And right now,
this is a horrible thing you're watching,
which the chances of this winding up,
you know, the great
Craig
Eric Spillman is right there
at the intersection of Sunset in the 405.
Eric, can you read
us? Go ahead and tell us what you see.
The sunset Boulevard Offramp is open
and it appears that
he they think that he might get off here
the whole way, going north along a 45.
It is an amazing sight.
Along the right hand shoulder,
people have pulled over, many of them
carrying signs, reading things
like save the Jews, Go O.J..
People are literally cheering him
on as he travels north down on the 405.
And we can only assume
that he plans to get off at sunset
and go towards perhaps his home.
He's moving over now, Eric.
Moving over to the right,
which means he may take that Sunset
Boulevard off ramp.
He's now moving over to the right lane.
Go follow Craig.
Are we approaching Sunset Boulevard?
Yes, we are.
Okay.
We are approaching Sunset Boulevard
off ramp.
But there's a crowd of people
who are on the bridge
and watching as he approaches
the sunset Boulevard.
Eric.
Eric, it looks it appears now
as though he is getting as I recall,
there are two lanes on the on the Sunset
Boulevard off ramp.
He is in one of them
and that's the lane he would be using.
He is. It looks like he's getting off.
Okay.
Well, it looks like he is getting off
at the off ramp at sunset.
Okay. Getting off.
He's on the off ramp now.
Coming
up, coming up the off ramp at sunset.
Lots of people at the overpass at sunset
and possibly here will be a westbound
turn in route to Brentwood.
That's right.
Like I said, in the left lane, now
making
making a left turn to the intersections
free and clear and now making a left
turn westbound on sunset.
All right.
And he must have gone right by you.
Eric and I have been.
We're staying ahead of it.
We're going to his mansion
believing that he's going there.
But he it was an amazing situation
on that overpass there.
There were people
running around on top of there.
I don't know how he's going to be able
to drive through all those people.
All along Sunset Boulevard.
There are
people stopped as well ahead of the chase.
We can only assume he's going to his home
on Rockingham in Brentwood.
Okay, Eric,
that that's exactly what had happened.
He did take that that Sunset Boulevard off
ramp, as we speculated.
And now he is proceeding
west on Sunset Boulevard.
He just went past Woodburn
and will be approaching Barrington Avenue.
And there's a red light at the track
and there are lights on this.
I don't know what he's going to do, how
he's going to respond to traffic lights.
He has had to cope with that.
But there's quite a lot of traffic lights.
We're hearing the sirens behind us now.
He's right behind us.
We're hearing the sirens.
The police have their sirens on.
Both sides of the street, have pedestrian
traffic.
Billy said he just went past Barrington.
It's only Barrington,
followed by the sheriff there, Orange
County Sheriff Santana, police officers
who are in pursuit.
Remember, there are people there
in that mansion. And
I don't think law enforcement wants
any kind of scenes to take place.
Then again, it is possible
he may have said on the phone,
all I want to do
is see my mother and children
and then I will surrender
so that is also a point for speculation.
It's hard to say what in the world
is on his mind at this point.
That's right.
This is the back way
that he got to his mansion.
That's right. Okay.
We're following
not only black and whites
with their sirens on
and their lights flashing, but again,
there's about ten private citizens
on motorcycles
who joined the pursuit as well.
And we can see close to the house now
very, very close.
We're right in the neighborhood.
We are right on the block
where his house is.
Okay.
And he is pulling in to the driveway.
Come around.
Someone is going to the door right now are
okay,
We're pulling up.
Let me tell you what I could see.
We've just turned the corner.
We'll take it.
It's total chaos here.
Motorcycles,
black and white, people running around,
officers getting out of their cars
with their
with their batons, people running, people
keeping that.
They're keeping our cameras away.
They won't let our cameras through.
Okay, I can understand that.
But we do have an aerial view, Eric,
is that something out of this of pointed
out of the window there?
Hell on the passenger side. Well, it did.
There's that just
the mirror might be the mirror,
but he's right
in the courtyard of his office and
he was evidently not driving obviously.
So he would be sitting right over
there possibly on that side.
But the gates were opened.
He went right through.
Someone came up to him
and then was chased away by
whoever the driver was
and two uniformed officers or a uniformed
man came up and pulled him away,
flashing lights on both sides.
And we are right here at a
at a standoff as details develop here,
we we should be able to see quite clearly
what will take place.
I doubt that he will be leaving again.
The police now know where he is.
We have found him.
The door is opening
and let's see what happens now.
We'll watch with you.
This is the driver's side of the vehicle.
Okay.
Someone just got out of the vehicle
approaching the front door.
At this point, I, I
from the information
that I've gathered up to this point, it
it appears some someone came back back
to the vehicle and entered the vehicle.
Uh, listen, you can't get around me here.
Maybe you can come back the other way.
So we can.
Okay.
That is the man that got out of the car
That presumably is our Cowlings vehicle.
And Cowlings,
we believe that to be Al Cowlings
holding his hand up, his palm up,
perhaps toward the police officers
behind him,
pointing toward the front door to O.J.
Simpson's home,
obviously having a conversation
with someone inside at this point.
Okay. Here's a believe.
A man is pleading to negotiate
with people here, the police, obviously,
and it's obviously very stressful
down there from from these pictures.
As you can see, a very delicate situation
taking place as we watch here.
Your parents,
from what we're hearing on the scanner,
they are trying to put a phone call,
perhaps from O.J.
through to his mother.
They're trying to arrange that right now.
It's going to be getting dark pretty soon.
The sun sets, I believe, around 804 today.
It's 820 now, so the sun will say 218.
I have.
So the sun set about 14 minutes ago.
But we have with us over here
John Duncan
with the LAPD public information officer.
Can you tell us
what's going on over there?
Is there a negotiation taking place?
There's we're not going to discuss
what's taking place here at this time.
We'll get back with you.
You're just going to have to bear with us.
It's a real sensitive point in this thing.
Okay.
Well, there's there's
clearly a negotiation going on
regardless of what he said or not.
They're not just sitting there
looking at each other.
I can guarantee you
the instant that the authorities believe
this coverage is detrimental,
then we will stop this coverage.
Okay.
Al Cowlings being used up to this point
as a as a verbal intermediary
and now apparently as a physical
one as well.
And Al Cowlings is seeing his friend now
threatening, at any rate, certainly
by implication, could kill himself,
you know, trying desperately
to keep that from happening.
This is Larry King and Washington's gang
atop the scene now night in Brentwood.
We understand something is breaking.
Let's go to our other affiliate,
take to TV Channel 11.
Get out of a hurry.
Okay. We have some new information here.
He has been arrested.
You're hearing anything at all?
We're
we have been staying
atop the scene with you all day
and all night, as we always do at CNN.
And we have now received a report
from Greg Lemond.
We have Greg Lemond on the phone with us.
Greg, can you now confirm that O.J.
Simpson is arrested?
Yes, sir.
He is in custody over a very
what seemed like long, dramatic moments.
I was fortunate enough to be listening
to a very sophisticated police
scanner via a local radio station.
I was listening to a police officer
talking back and forth with one another.
There was a moment of silence.
And then all of a sudden
the officer said, We have a code four,
which means
they have their man in custody.
This all happened just moments ago.
It's been a very dramatic and
topsy turvy day
and it's certainly been an emotional one.
What a day.
Greg, thank you for a terrific
reporting all day long.
Thank you.
Thanks to all of our people associated
with our affiliates
in Los Angeles at Channel five and 11.
Greg LaMotte
and the rest of the journalists who cover
this all day long, and to our aerial views
that very carried us, that
Al Cowlings and O.J.
Simpson flew two counties to his home
and finally to arrest tonight
in Los Angeles, west for O.J.
Simpson. There are no words for
this great
United States bin Laden explosion.
Donald Trump with a hoax shout out,
why am I under arrest by.